It's a blockbuster holiday weekend.
The highly anticipated
movies, Oppenheimer and Barbie,
are hitting theaters today.
Our Sara Sidner sat down
with two stars of the Barbie movie
last month.
Before, I should note,
the actors went on strike.
And she joins us now.
So, Sara,
a lot of people don't know
this about Margot Robbie,
but she played a really critical role
and even getting this movie
to be created in the first place.
What did they tell you?
Some interesting things.
I asked them,
I said, look, when I was a little girl,
I didn't play with Barbie.
I was too busy jumping out of trees.
And you were trying
to be better than that?
Well, no,
I was just trying to be better
than the boys all the time.
Was very competitive.
And Margot Robbie
jumps up and says, me, too.
And then America Ferrera says,
I didn't play with Barbie either.
And I was like, So what's with the movie?
And both of them
It's a great follow up.
Both of them said, This movie has heart.
Yeah.
It will make you laugh,
but it might also make you cry.
It's deep.
Barbie is deep.
That's what I learned.
Take a listen.
All right.
I'm gonna start with you.
Margot,
everyone makes Barbie into who
they think she is
because she doesn't talk.
She doesn't walk.
So we use our imaginations.
How did you decide
who Barbie was going to be in this film?
To be honest,
Greta knew from the beginning,
really, that she wanted Barbie
to have the classic hero's journey.
She actually used, like,
Buddha's journey to enlightenment
as a reference.
And I was like, Okay, well,
I didn't see that coming
but now that you've said it, it
does make perfect sense.
And so
suddenly, she did
have, like,
this framework of the narrative.
And within that,
we can have all these conversations on
so many different levels.
And and what we wanted to do with
those conversations is kind of honor
the legacy
that the 64 years of Barbie has created.
You know,
and also bring it into today's day.
You know, have
I have culturally relevant conversations.
Okay.
I do have to ask America
how deliciously
ironic is it that Ryan Gosling's age
became the thing that people were
talking about,
not the woman, but the man for once.
Oh yeah. It is ironic.
Yeah, I just heard that.
That's the thing.
You know, that's the
that's
the fate of the cans in Barbie land, is
they essentially have to suffer
a lot of the
the fate of women in the real world.
And and, you know, it it
it it kind of highlights its stupidity,
really.
But but
it's you know, the
movie turns a lot of things on its head.
And and I in my opinion, tells us more
about us as humans
than than really,
you know, a movie about dolls.
And America
you play one of the few characters
who is not a doll, who is not a Barbie.
In the movie.
You're a Real-Life Person
going through Real-Life Challenges
as a working woman.
What happens when you and Barbie meet
finally?
I don't want to spoil anything,
but I don't spoil
and give us a reason for
the moment.
That Gloria and Barbie connect.
I just started, like, bawling, and.
And it felt so
beautiful that, you know, a grown woman
could explore
her imagination and her playfulness and
and really be enthusing tastic
about something that she loved
and something that was playful
and inspiring to her.
And that that didn't have to be
in contradiction to her
as, like, a grown serious,
professional woman.
I have to be honest, though.
I was not a Barbie obsessed girl.
I was too busy
jumping out of trees
and racing boys
and trying to be better than the boys.
I was exactly like playing with Barbies.
I was I was not a Barbie girl.
Were you?
I know.
I was exactly like you, Sarah.
I was like doing
trying to beat the boys at everything.
And I asked my mom
before this
presser was like, Mom,
do you have any pictures of me,
like playing with Barbies
or opening a Barbie on Christmas?
I that it'd be really helpful
for no comparison.
And she was like you.
I couldn't even get you to wear a dress.
I was like,
I mean, a
like we couldn't afford Barbies.
Be like, I don't know.
I just like didn't
this world of Barbie
didn't feel like it had very much for me
in it, to be perfectly honest.
But that is what is so beautiful to me
about this moment
and getting to be a part of this story
that is exposed
landing the world of Barbie
to include the rest of us.
And what I think the movie gives us
is the permission
to be more of who we are
that like Barbie gets to
that we're all Barbie
and Barbie gets to be whatever
the hell Barbie wants to be.
Margo, what are you hoping to impart
to the audience with this film?
The feeling of like,
yes, it's like you want
to do
this and you want to be a good mom
and you want to be a good friend
and you want to be a good husband
and you want to be an ally
and you want to be an activist,
but you want to just do your job
and you want to get through the day
and blah, blah blah, blah, blah.
I find all of that on your shoulders
and just say you're already doing great.
You are doing great because you are you,
and that is enough.
That's what I would give.
It's like the erasing of imposter
syndrome, right?
I think we've all suffered from that
and women more than anyone else.
So that's a beautiful thing.
Did the Barbie sleepover happen?
I heard that
that director, Greta Gerwig, was like,
You guys need to have this Yes.
And it was so much fun.
We had a Barbie sleepover.
The kids were invited to visit,
not to stay over. Obviously,
we all were
at pajamas and ordered room service
and we shared beds and we played games.
And we all discovered
how incredibly competitive
America is when it comes to games.
Let's talk
about how Ryan said
a man in a kilt
to play bagpipes out in 3 minutes
and then recite the speech
from a Braveheart
and that was just it was just amazing.
That doesn't bond you. I don't know what.
I still don't get it.
Was it an inside joke?
No, there was no relationship.
There was no Braveheart connection.
Was he trying to say like Fredo, like,
you must have been trying
to say something?
Ryan, I guess
I feel like he was bragging.
He was like before we were started,
it was like a
yeah, a rallying cry, perhaps.
Ladies, I.
I actually was like, oh, my.
Going to see the Barbie.
But the way you've described it,
it's like something
I think the girlfriends
could go to together
and buddies
could go to together with the kids
and just enjoy the ride.
It's a party, and everyone is invited.
All right, spoiler alert.
Here's a lesson
you will learn from this movie,
because I may or may not have seen it
Being human is hard.
Being a female human is even harder,
but it's worth it.
That's a great moral of the story.
That's my Zen for the morning.
Barbie is deep,
so I have a theory about the bagpipes.
I've heard that story before.
Maybe it was like a primal male scream
like they weren't.
The cannons were not allowed
at the sleepover.
So they really just had, like,
the Braveheart thing.
That's my dad, actually.
That's it.
That completely and utterly funny.
Can I weigh in here?
I was going to say nobody's talking. Yes.
I mean,
I don't feel you tell us can stop.
What I will say is like that
that move for be like leadership
perspective to me is like,
oh, yeah, that's totally dope.
And then, like, I hear that describe it.
I was like, oh, wow, that's super weird.
That's me.
Regardless of audience,
but particularly with that audience,
I do need to remind people
this is a Warner Brothers
Discovery program.
We are also owned by Warner
Brothers Discovery.
But they did this obviously
before the strike
because this is not
you're not allowed to
sort of promote things.
So that's where we are.
I enjoyed it.
That being said,
we love your Barbie Pink.
Thank you.
Thank you for
gracing us with your feelings.
I was going to say
pausing and waiting
so we could get to Barbie cake pop.
We need this happiness.
This is that.
Thank you, Sarah. Thanks, buddy.